[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story a show of support and a
military boost for Ukraine at the G7
Summit as the U.S agrees allies can send
fighter jets to help repel Russia
see you on Monday bye
the final farewell Phillips Schofield
quits ITV show this morning after 20
years at the helm
[Applause]
Man City clinched the Premier League
title without even kicking a ball today
after a shock defeat for Rivals Arsenal
questions over whether the Home
Secretary broke the ministerial code by
asking for special treatment dealing
with a speeding offense
tributes to Martin Amos the author of
money and London Fields who's died at
the age of 73.
and shin Fein called for power sharing
to return at Stormont once more as local
elections in Northern Ireland show
they'll become the largest party for the
first time
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in The Press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
a very good evening thanks for joining
us of all the Ukrainian presidents
overseas visits few have felt quite as
consequential and controversial as
today's trip to the G7 it began with
what Vladimir zelenski described as a
historic move by the United States
President Biden giving his approval for
allies to supply Ukraine with
American-made F-16 fighter jets it also
saw sanctions on Russia tightened and
president zielinski given face time with
world leaders like India's prime
minister who until now have refused to
back Ukraine in the face of Russian
aggression the Kremlin responded by
saying the day's developments were an
escalation that carried enormous risks
for those involved our political editor
Beth Rigby sent this report from the
Japanese city of Hiroshima where G7
leaders are meeting for their annual
Summit
president zielinski landing in Japan
stepping into the arms of the world's
most powerful democracies
on the sidelines of the summit waiting
in the wings to embrace the support of
key partners
the U.S promised that allies will supply
F-16 fighter jets in his words a
historic moment
president a major move in Ukraine's
quest to end this war it's a good day
isn't it a good day
and these leaders no doubt agree
standing United against Russian
aggression
the geopolitical Outlook so far from
Bright but to hope that peace will
prevail these allies hand in glove ready
to support Ukraine my word is to say
that from the very beginning you know
that France is that
shoulder to shoulder with you we are
here and we will be here to this very
end be sure about that thank you for all
this support and we spoke a lot about
about future Jazz collection and I want
to thank you and all the partners about
this decision about training mission is
really really very very important
close allies and firm friends
who have put in the time and effort to
make sure they're aligned not just on
Ukraine but on future threats too the G7
leaders also condemning an increasingly
muscular China expressing serious
concern over the economic and Military
danger Beijing poses in the final Summit
statement
as these democracies defend their ground
back in the days of Donald Trump and
Boris Johnson g7s were more often than
not punctuated by division but allies
here have sought to portray a united
front against common threats standing
literally shoulder to shoulder with
president zielinski and Ukraine whilst
also issuing a joint statement
criticizing China's increasing economic
and Military aggression no time to look
away Russia absent but acutely aware of
what's going on here tonight say in the
west decision to provide Jets is a
colossal risk but one allies are willing
finally to take bath Rigby's Sky News in
Hiroshima
while President zelenski was in Japan a
mercenary group laying Siege to his
country on behalf of Russia claimed to
have taken control of the Ukrainian city
of bakmut I claim it should be said that
that was swiftly denied by Ukraine's
military the Wagner group leader made
the claim in this video posted online
but a spokesperson of The Joint Forces
of Ukraine told Sky News this is not
true fighting is going on in the city
well Sky's Alex wassuit was in Batman
this week and witnessed the fighting
taking place so Alex is this all part of
the propaganda war or is Russia on the
brink of taking full control
it is extremely hard to say exactly what
is going on it is a case of claim and
counter claim uh tonight but if you
actually look at what's going on in the
ground whether or not it has fallen to
the last building it doesn't really make
much of a difference the soldiers I
spoke to Ukrainian soldiers said that
the city really was hanging by a thread
about 95 percent of it in recent weeks
has been captured by the Russians there
are only a few blocks left now you've
got any precaution the leader of the
Wagner paramilitary group says they have
taken all of it now that has been denied
by Ukrainian defense Ministry but
effectively the city is now anyway under
Russian control what does it mean well
it's certainly a symbolic victory for
Russia but it comes at a great cost it's
taken them months to capture what I
think is Ukraine's 56th largest city
pre-war population of around 50 000. so
it's a pretty small place I've been
there many times throughout this
conflict so in that sense it's not very
significant they've also spent an
enormous amount of material tens of
thousands of soldiers have been killed
there but they will finally be able to
say you know to Their audience at home
to Russian people that they have uh had
some kind of Victory from the Ukrainian
point of view if indeed it has fallen it
is going to be a psychological blow they
have also thrown an enormous amount of
resource at it but really it's
fundamentally unlikely to change the
course of this war it is of limited
strategic value the bigger question
revolves around what happens now with
Ukraine's spring counter-offensive or it
may very well turn into be a summer uh
counter-offensive that is more likely to
change the course of the war when it
starts
Alex and denipro for us tonight thank
you
back here TV presenter Phillip Schofield
has quit as a presenter on itvs this
morning after more than 20 years in the
role it follows weeks of speculation
about a growing Rift with co-presenter
Holly Willoughby and a day after his
brother Timothy Schofield was jailed
over child sex offenses Emma birchley
reports see you on Monday bye
little did he know but after more than
two decades this was to be Phillip
schofield's last goodbye from the famous
this morning sofa
it was on Thursday the day before his
brother Timothy Scofield would be
sentenced to 12 years in prison for a
string of child sex offenses and against
a backdrop of rumors that his
relationship with co-host Holly
Willoughby had fallen apart
in a statement he said recently this
morning itself has become the story
throughout my career in TV including the
very difficult last few days I have
always done my best to be honorable and
kind I understand that ITV has decided
the current situation can't go on and I
want to do what I can to protect the
show that I love so I have agreed to
step down from this morning with
immediate effect
no mention of Holly Willoughby
things had been tough for the pair after
being accused of cue jumping to see the
queen lying in state in September
and he took a pre-planned break from the
show during his brother's trial which
added further strain
jurors had heard that Timothy Scofield
had told Philip that he and his victim
had watched pornography together
following conviction Philip said he no
longer had a brother but despite the
rumors about a Fallout with his co-host
Phillip Schofield reportedly told the
sun earlier this month that he and Holly
were still the best of friends although
admitting the last few weeks hadn't been
easy oh it must have been absolute hell
for him to to wake up and they look at
the papers and the big stories of the
day at the top of their show they have
been having to avoid from the biggest
tabloid stories at least of the week
which is them uh I suspect he has been
been going through a difficult time
personally it hasn't shown on air until
I think this week it's an accumulation
of things that seems to have affected
the relationship and maybe
may be affected Holly willoughby's brand
all you can be in your life is honest
with yourself yeah and I was getting to
the point where I knew I wasn't honest
with myself
the pairs Bond had once been strong
Schofield married for 27 years crying on
Holly's shoulder in February 2020 after
announcing that he was gay
she was quick to release a statement
after the news of his departure saying
it's been over 13 great years presenting
this morning with Phil and I want to
take this opportunity to thank him for
all of his knowledge his experience and
his humor the sofa won't feel the same
without him
Holly will be back on that sofa on the
5th of June after the half-term break
for Philip a new Prime Time show is on
its way presumably once the dust has
settled
Emma birchley Sky News
now Manchester City retained their
premier league title today without even
having to kick a ball their third title
in a row was confirmed after
second-placed Arsenal lost at Nottingham
Forest giving City an unassailable lead
at the top of the table now after that
result Manchester City posted this video
the team celebrating the results
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
just fantastic Sky's Frozen Ward is in
Manchester for us this evening Fraser
the team delighted the fans to
absolutely a bit of an early celebration
as well I don't think many people
thought that Arsenal would slip up quite
how they did against Nottingham Forest
down at City ground today great news for
Nottingham Forest it ensures their
Premier League survival but also well
they started to let things slip a little
while ago they had a string of drawers
and they got beaten by City 4-1 and then
another defeat by Brighton last week
rarely put them up against it
statistically if they'd won today they
could still have potentially won the
Premier League title but uh everyone's
money I think was always on Manchester
City to do it even if Arsenal had won
today would have needed City to to lose
two of the next three games and only get
a draw in the other one and I don't
think anyone thought that that was ever
going to happen I could have a chat with
a couple of the fans down here have come
down to celebrate they're about 100 or
so fans earlier on there's a few left
now can have a quick chat here with Tom
Tom how are you doing celebrating today
yeah did you think you'd be able to
celebrate today or did you think it was
going to be tomorrow when you take on
Chelsea here at the Etihad I think it'll
be a draw uh be fair and then we would
win it tomorrow and lift the Premier
League tomorrow so you thought also
we're going to draw today but you can
celebrate tonight yeah so all you've got
to do now is the treble is that doable
yeah I think we'll be United in the
final and then we'll be into Roland and
turkey
we're confident man that's what we like
to hear Jimmy let's have a chat with you
what did you make of it today did you
expect to win it today um to be fair I
was kind of up in a forest but I got a
draw so it's kind of in the bag if that
was the case
um but obviously great result but I
forgot what second gear tomorrow now
um so yeah decent and you can quite
literally be on the beach against
Brighton and then Bradford we don't have
to do anything now we can rest players
um but for me like if you've asked too
many people like the Rhythm goals so
playing like 60 minutes or so getting
back off but yeah mascara I mean all the
thought this season has been about the
possibility of a treble the first part
of it's been ticked off three games uh
three games early yeah Manchester United
in the FA Cup Final then enter in the
Champions League final is it on one game
at a time been a city if I'm long enough
to know like
anything can happen I'm quite
pessimistic as well so one game at a
time beat United and then it's on that's
it that's it one game is a time you
sound like a football manager so
celebrations down here tonight one day
early Chelsea here tomorrow that's when
you will have tens of thousands of fans
here really celebrating that Manchester
City win the third win in a row the
fifth in six seasons they are a
Powerhouse of Premier League football
they really are good stuff Fraser in
Manchester thank you
now labor tonight is calling for an
investigation into whether the Home
Secretary broke the ministerial code by
asking for special treatment dealing
with a speeding offense so let's bring
in our chief political correspondent
John Craig uh so John what's the
allegation here
well but just before she became a Home
Secretary uh last year when she was
attorney general she was done for
speeding instead of paying up paying the
fine accepting the points and so on all
going on on one of those speed awareness
courses where you have 10 or 20 or 25
people in the room she asked or she got
civil servants here when she just
arrived here as Home Secretary if she
could have a one-to-one a private speed
awareness course now this home office
civil servants initially said no they
consulted the cabinet office who backed
them and uh the uh so in in the end she
took the points and paid the fine but
now of course she's facing allegations
that she's broken the ministerial code
both labor and the liberal Democrats say
there needs to be an investigation by
the prime minister's ethics advisor
that's Laurie Magnus appointed towards
the end of last year Yvette Cooper the
shadow Home Secretary says the uh
disclosure that she tried to if you like
cheat the system or a Dodge a special
Dodger fine was shocking and as she said
this this is Yvette Cooper the Prime
Minister has promised Integrity
professionalism and accountability yet
it appears his home secretaries
blatantly flouting all three we need an
urgent investigation into what has gone
on here starting with Laurie Magnus
seeing how this is possibly compatible
with the ministerial code now we spoke
to the cabinet office what they said was
it would be it not be appropriate to
comment on the existence or content of
advice between government departments in
this case between the home office and
the cabinet office now friends of Sue
Ella Barbara are telling Sky News that
well the reason she didn't want to go to
one of these big speed awareness
sessions is she'd have to take her
protection officers with her and so she
didn't want to do that but she is under
pressure now from political opponents
remember she had to go as Home Secretary
briefly when she breached the
ministerial code last year over leaking
some Whitehall material to a Tory MP so
John Hayes it's come at the end of a bad
week she made a controversial some would
say inflammatory speech at a conference
just along down the road here early in
the week was told to stick to the day
job her personal poll ratings have
fallen and now she's facing the
possibility of an inquiry by the prime
minister's ethics advisor some of her
supporters will no doubt claim it's
another example of the civil servants
that blob as some call them trying to
bring down a Tory cabinet minister
John outside the home office thank you
now there was some sad news this evening
the author Martin Amos has died at the
age of 73 the influential writer of
novels including money London Fields and
the information passed away at his home
in Florida his wife the writer Isabel
Fonseca said he died of cancer of the
esophagus and in a tribute Martin amos's
publisher said the following we are
devastated at the death of our author
and Friend Martin Amos novelist essayist
memoirist critic stylist Supreme he was
always unfailingly warm kind and
generous to those fortunate enough to
work closely with him his death is an
enormous loss to all of us at penguin
random house and to the UK's cultural
landscape
also in a tribute the book of prize
released a statement saying we are
saddened to hear that Martin Amos one of
the most acclaimed and discussed
novelists of the past 50 years has died
our thoughts are with his family and
friends
police in Greater Manchester have
arrested a second person and seized 15
dogs in connection with the death of a
37 year old man Jonathan Hogg was
attacked in Lee on Thursday and died in
hospital after suffering serious
injuries
will be the largest party in local
government in Northern Ireland for the
first time in history counting has been
taking place throughout the day of votes
cast in Thursday's elections shufone
vice president Michelle O'Neill used the
result to repeat her call for the dup to
restore power sharing at Stormont well
here's the current state of the party
Shin Fein has secured 30.9 percent to
First preference votes so far followed
by the dep and then the alliance party
the results will decide who will
represent voters on 11 of Northern
Ireland's local councils our senior
Island correspondent David Blevins has
the latest from Belfast just a warning
his report does contain flash
photography
the rise and Rise of Sinn Fein the
largest party at Stormont now the
largest party in local government
Michelle O'Neill says the dup should
respect that mandate and restore power
sharing allowing her to become first
minister at last there shouldn't be any
delays we should not be willing to the
Autumn to have
a reason for it not to be said
AP are in a battle with the British
government and the people are the
collateral damage in the middle of that
battle and that's not acceptable it's
not good enough
turnout was lower in unionist areas but
the dup says there's clear support for
its boycott of devolution over
post-brexit trading Arrangements the
dup's
mandia strong
unionism for Northern Ireland to fix the
problems that confront us at the moment
to ensure that our place in the United
Kingdom is not only respected but is
protected in law
most of the focus has been on the two
largest parties but there is a quiet
Revolution continuing in the Middle
Ground the alliance party which doesn't
designate as unionist our nationalist
cementing its position as the third
force in Northern Irish politics
foreign
but the alliance leader is worried about
some sections of the community
disengaging altogether ultimately if
people are sitting at home it's because
they don't feel that there's anything to
come
to come over and I believe it's
important that people participate and I
would hope that other parties would be
concerned when they see sections of the
electorate not failing apart not feeling
motivated and not wanting to come out
and participate in the elections
with no devolved government in police
many people are disillusioned by the
political stalemate here things don't
change so I just expect the results are
going to be the same as they were last
year I think there's a sleeping giant in
the middle that's not
um this disengaged from Liberal politics
there is apathy and it's a shame but
there is a growing apathy
the more things change the more they
stay the same in a divided Society still
struggling to emerge from the politics
of them and US David Blevins Sky News in
Belfast
Surfers took to the waters around the UK
today in protest at the state they're
left in by water companies the industry
apologized this week over the amount of
raw sewage pumped out into rivers and
seas and pledged to spend 10 billion
pounds to clean up their act Skies Aisha
zahid reports from Brighton
I am sick of seeing sewage in our
beautiful beaches and rivers here in
Brighton their message is a clear one
these campaigners are protesting against
sewage spills in a demonstration
organized by Surfers against sewage the
paddle boarders kayakers and swimmers
are calling for bathing Waters to be
protected from raw sewage it's a really
important time right now for protesting
on water quality we've finally got the
public to notice we've got communities
nursing we've even got media Outlets
running their own campaigns the time is
now to make the water companies notice
the government and regulators and
actually enact some change that's why
they also want to see sewage discharges
as a whole cut by 90 in the next seven
years their demands come days after the
industry apologized the water companies
have pledged 10 billion pounds to
cleaning up their act but with more than
300 000 sewage stores in England alone
last year these protesters are skeptical
it's going to make any real change
it should be a safe place to swim should
be a safe place to paddle board but it's
not and we've lost you know months of
good swimming last year my daughter got
sick in a river last year the profits
that the water companies are taking that
the shareholders are taking and that
that money needs to be spent on
infrastructure protests were held across
the UK including here in Scarborough
where things looked a little different
our spoke
we're not
the water here is currently deemed to be
too dangerous but that didn't stand in
anyone's way there's concerns over what
this all means for the local economy the
water companies are going to have to put
an end to it because tourists are coming
here and forgot to be told that I can't
go in the sea then where are they going
to go this is the primary reason why
people come to the seaside water UK are
adamant that this time they will get it
right in a statement the chair of the
organization said the message from the
water and sewage industry is clear we
are sorry more should have been done to
address the issue of spillages sooner
and the public is right to be upset
about the current quality of our rivers
and beaches we have listened and have an
unprecedented plan to start to put it
right
it's clear that resolving the problem
will take time but this may well be the
point we see a turn of the tide Aisha
zahid Sky News in Brighton
let's get the latest on that Manchester
City news and the rest of the sport with
Matt
the Sky News sports bulletin is brought
to you by Vitality getting more people
more active live life with vitality
hi my name is Khadija and I train as a
jockey and this is a day in my life
during Ramadan
thank you
[Music]
Big Boy Ramadan is a time during the
year where I can really simplify and
break down what it means to be a Muslim
for me it's also a month of discipline
riding out having a routine takes
discipline so we come in and
get the horses cleaned and tacked up
grab your equipment get on can you
explain what Siri is it's a meal just
before Fajr which is just Before Sunrise
um
encouraged us to eat a small meal
so we can keep going through the day
whilst we're fasting it's a very blessed
meal so I try when I can and when I'm
not too tired to eat this morning I had
porridge and a leftover sandwich
[Music]
in times of riding out it's not too hot
I only have two horses a day in the
mornings
when I'm writing more it's a sort of
three four horses a day it can get quite
tough but
currently I've just started too so we're
all good so far can be quite tough it is
a lot of patience but once you get a
routine of just eating slightly later
and having breakfast so early you just
sort of like your body adjusts to it
also reminds you that like
you know we are simple creatures human
beings and you know we're not as
Invincible as we think and I think in
the 21st century we forget how fragile
as humans we are and how much we depend
on things
um and for me specifically like in a
world where everything is so easy to get
having you know having restrictions and
practicing like restricting your desires
is is all about sort of like
self-discipline and understanding your
limits this is a day in the life of me
training in in the mornings I'm going to
head back to my house to pray the heart
of NASA and during Ramadan my goal is to
try and pray my prayers on time so I've
gotta head back quite quickly
[Music]
so after my training I always try and
grab a shower and prepare for my second
prayer of the day with the hood before I
can do that I have to do a lot which is
a cleansing process how often do you
read the Quran Ramadan it is one of the
main things that we're supposed to focus
on is returning back to the quad and
getting closer to the Quran so I'm going
to make a huge effort to try and read
this more often
now it's time to free acid
so the sun setting which means that I
need to go and pray my fourth prayer of
the day in maharab I'm gonna make my
although and get ready for iftar to
break my fast
foreign
so normally I start off by breaking fast
with a few dates normally I have some
medjool dates or my favorites are from
Algeria and Tunisia but that's just my
personal preference and then I have some
grapes sometimes I have watermelon as
well and strawberries and berries
depends what I can get my hands on
earlier in the day I also have to
consider getting my protein intake
because I only have two opportunities to
eat during the day during Ramadan so
that would be drink if blood and then my
sweetheart in the morning
I try my best to incorporate like
chicken and protein and substitutions
for proteins and sometimes I get some
vegetarian stuff I try and make sure I
cover my water intake because I get so
dehydrated during the day especially if
I'm training and then afterwards I have
a starter my mum normally makes a
beautiful soup called shut up
however unfortunately when I'm training
and I'm away from home I'm not that good
at making it so I don't even try
and then I have Samosa my Mom normally
fries them up and she makes them when
I'm away I just buy them so yeah I'm a
little bit lazy but
um there's plenty of meat and vegetables
in the samosas but they're not 100 as
healthy but I sort of see them as like a
treat by that point my appetite is
shrunk so like sometimes I get so full
just after a few bits but my main meal
is normally like quite protein heavy and
I normally have like a rice and Curry or
rice and chicken
um the Sky News sports bulletin is 14 by
vitality
thanks Matan that was Sky News at 10
coming up as always we're going to take
a first look at tomorrow's papers in the
Press preview including the Phillips
Schofield store on most of the front
pages including the mirror the headline
they've gone with at the